I work with a lot of engineers project
managers and scientists on how to
communicate more effectively using humor
and from time to time I get someone who
is worried about humor because they
think their work is far too serious to
do something like have fun ignoring the
fact that using humor will actually help
you do your job better while helping you
enjoy it more I'm always reminded of a
story about Abraham Lincoln Lincoln was
well known for his humor in and out of
the office to the point that there are
multiple books dedicated to the subject
but my favorite story of Lincoln takes
place during the Civil War
the year was 1862 the United States was
in the first year of the Civil War a war
that would result more American
casualties than any other war before or
since a time when the country was on the
verge of division and battling one of
the greatest civil rights violations of
all time
slavery Abraham Lincoln called together
a special session of his war cabinet
members to discuss an incredibly
important topic every member of the
cabinet was there the Secretary of War
the Secretary of Treasury the Attorney
General and more as people entered the
room Lincoln was reading a book and
smiling to himself once the people were
settled Lincoln started the meeting by
reading a humor story from the book
after reading it Lincoln laughed aloud
along with no one else the room was
silent so Lincoln decided to read
another story and again silence but
Lincoln didn't waver he didn't apologize
or feel like he made a mistake instead
he said gentlemen why don't you laugh
with the fearful strain that is upon me
night and day if I did not laugh I
should die and you need this medicine as
much as I do the next document Lincoln
read and the purpose of the meeting was
the first draft of the Emancipation
Proclamation one of the most important
documents in this country's history
since the Constitution and Bill of
Rights Lincoln knew the value of humor
and knew that levity doesn't negate the
magnitude or seriousness of a situation
but rather helps us through it so my
response to people who claim their work
is too serious for humor I ask is it
more serious in the Civil War or the
abolishment of slavery so why not use a
little bit of humor in the workplace to
find out more visit
that works at WWE um er that works calm